hey 42 here there's a popular exercise
uninspired fiction writers sometimes use
to help get the
creative juices flowing here's how it
works
take one everyday object a toothbrush
perhaps or
a roll of masking tape next place it in
a location
it could be a high-end restaurant your
favorite childhood park
or an abandoned warehouse now
introduce a character male female
young old it doesn't matter but someone
you know well
finally imagine he has a strong need or
desire
perhaps he wants to build a hugely
successful drug empire
or become the next wimbledon champion at
any cost
or maybe his name is mr blonde and he
just wants to dance
this method helps writers create
entirely fictional stories
by bringing together real life details
in a way that never actually
happened that's great for someone
suffering from writer's block
but it turns out our brains do something
very similar
without us ever even realizing which is
rather more worrying
our memories are essentially mosaics
made from
different sensory inputs smells sights
snippets of conversation that sort of
thing
that's why when you think back on a
treasured memory it
rarely if ever feels like playing back a
film
instead you remember certain elements
distinctly
and the rest of the picture is a bit of
a blur
each one of your memories consists of a
real physical network in the brain
that connects each of those sensory
inputs
recalling a given memory strengthens
that network
whilst rarely accessed memories will
slowly degrade
it's a completely natural process and
one that's going on in your brain
all the time including right now
but this constant state of flux new
memories forming
and old ones being discarded can
sometimes result in your brain
making mistakes just like our author
with writer's block
your brain can end up putting real
memories together
in ways that never actually happened
when that
occurs a false memory is formed
it's a process that happens entirely
without our realizing
and to all intents and purposes a false
memory is completely indistinguishable
from all the other real ones we have as
weird as the idea of false memories may
be
it's possible you've noticed one before
without really realizing
many of us think we remember certain
events from early childhood
based on old photographs or on stories
we're told
by our parents but it's often hard to
know for sure
whether we really do remember what
happened
or if that memory has been implanted by
what we've seen or
heard about the events since
in many cases those are simply false
memories
that kind of thing might not seem like a
big deal after all misremembering where
you left your house keys last night
is unlikely to cost you more than a few
minutes of frantic searching the next
morning
and a childhood memory that may or may
not be real
probably won't have any impact on your
life at all
but when you think about it your
memories are so much more than
vague childhood recollections and random
facts and figures
memory is a record of your life it's the
sum total of everything that happens to
you in the past
and it informs every decision you're
going to make in the future
in a way your memory isn't just an
important part
of who you are it is you
and when seen in that light the idea it
might be full of things that never
actually happened
or at least didn't happen exactly quite
how you think they did
is an altogether scarier thought beyond
simply creating false memories just to
mess with
us our minds fool us in all sorts of
different ways
one of the most common is down to
something called rosy retrospection
named after the idiom rose tinted
spectacles
this type of memory illusion is
characterized as a tendency to filter
out
the less desirable elements of a past
event if you were to recall a holiday
for example
you might remember the feeling of sun on
your skin
or an accordion playing melodically
beneath your balcony
you're less likely to remember rocking
that lobster look from day two
or the accordionist feeling especially
expressive
at 5am retrospection works a little
differently to
negativity bias which is a tendency we
all have
and is particularly common in young
adults to pay more attention to negative
information when making judgments and
decisions
rosy retrospection is more about how we
remember past events and our brains
manipulation of those memories
and the more time that passes after an
event
the rosier our recollections of it tends
to
be in 2013 a study was carried out to
investigate
how marathon runners felt about a race
both before it happened
and after they finished immediately
after the race
runners who didn't achieve their
pre-race target
were less interested in running another
marathon in the future
compared to those who did hit their
target but
four weeks later the runners who'd
failed to reach their goals were
actually
more keen to run another marathon than
those who succeeded
the researchers involved with the study
suggested this bizarre optimism that
emerged
over time might be down to runners
filtering out memories of the physical
pain and
mental torment suffered during the race
and focusing instead on the
rosier aspects of what a marathon
represented to them
a chance to achieve a goal rosy
retrospection bias is closely linked to
another phenomenon
the reminiscence bump memory scientists
have found that we don't recall events
about ourselves equally across
our lifespan instead there's an increase
in the amount
and quality of memories that formed
between our late
teens and early 20s and this increase is
especially common for anyone aged 40 and
above
so why that particular time period
why the hell would we want to remember
the agonizing angst of our late
teens or the tumultuous uncertainty of
our early twenties
because that's when we form our identity
for most people this is the time of
first relationships
of flying the nest finding work visiting
new places
meeting new people with opinions and
outlooks
difference to the ones we grew up with
and all of those things have a huge
impact
on our sense of self and the memories we
associate with our self-image remain
highly accessible especially later in
life when our identities
are more or less established when you
combine the reminiscence bump with rosy
retrospection bias
you can see why it might lead to
something called
declinism the widely held belief that in
the good old days
prices were sensible politicians were
trustworthy
and children respected their elders
false memories can corrupt our sense of
self and even influence the way we
interact with the world around us
and if all of this is making you start
to distrust your own memories a little
that's probably a good thing because it
only gets worse from here on in
imagine you're invited to take part in a
memory study
one where the researchers are trying to
develop the most effective techniques
for recalling accurate memories you
arrive for your appointment which takes
place in a typical office
and notice that somewhat reassuringly
the interviewer's bookshelves are lined
with volumes on memory retrieval
the interviewer let's call him bob
begins by asking you about your day
after a bit of small talk he asks you to
remember an event that took place when
you were 14.
he doesn't tell you exactly what it is
but uses gentle prompts to
coax the details out of you you quickly
recall those details and it isn't
long before you're proudly describing
the time you
filled your sister's room with red
balloons whilst she watched
it downstairs in an attempt to give her
a heart attack at bedtime
bob smiles congratulates you for
recalling your sadistic memory so
accurately
and tells you it matches perfectly with
your sister's own account
he then asks you to recall something
that happened when you were 19.
a criminal act which resulted in police
contact
when you explain you don't remember that
event at all
he seems disappointed and reminds you
he's received
very detailed information about it from
a close family member
when you still can't remember after a
few prompts
bob scribbles something down on his
clipboard
reassures you that many people can't
recall certain events if they haven't
thought about them for a while
and says you're likely to recall it
eventually
if you try hard enough fast forward to a
few interviews later
and there's a high chance you'll be
admitting to a crime
you didn't commit and recounting every
minute detail
of how you did it because that's the
very situation
28 participants found themselves in in
as part of a psychology experiment
carried out by julia shaw
and stephen porter of the 28
participants asked to recall this
made-up criminal event from their
childhood
21 claimed to remember it
of those 21 eight described assaulting
another person
six described a theft and seven
described assaulting another person
with a weapon the point of this
experiment was to show that
with a few common interview techniques
like
building rapport exerting social
pressure
and using suggestion or presenting false
evidence
many of us would admit to a crime we
didn't commit
but terrifying as it may be to think our
own minds can be tricked so easily
it doesn't stop there because what if
you had a false memory
not of a crime you committed but one
someone else did
mistakenly accusing someone of theft or
assault
could impact their lives forever if you
were believed
and what about more serious crimes are
our memories so unreliable we could
falsely accuse someone else of murder
actually yes because that's exactly what
happened to a man
called george franklin in 1969
an 80 year old girl called susan nason
disappeared
on her way to school in foster city
california
she would never be seen alive again and
three months later her body was found
near her home for years investigators
attempted to track down the perpetrator
without any success
and the trail eventually went cold
but two decades later they got a big
break
one of susan's friends eileen franklin
lipscore
claims to have recovered a repressed
memory
in which she witnessed her father rape
and
kill susan her father george franklin
was promptly put on trial with his own
daughter as the star witness for the
prosecution
the case relied heavily on eileen's
account of the incident
and of the theory of repressed memories
a concept originally put forward by
sigmund freud
the idea is that memories about
traumatic events can be stored in our
unconscious mind
where they are usually blocked from
conscious recall
as a kind of built-in safety mechanism
to protect us from the horror and trauma
the prosecution argued eileen had
repressed
all memory of the murder until something
her own daughter did
two decades later had brought everything
bubbling back to the surface
there were however some disparities
between eileen's memory of the assault
and the evidence found by the police and
we're talking pretty big details here
like the time of day
she'd seen it happen and where it had
taken place
eileen did eventually amend her
statement to one that matched the
evidence more closely
but even the amended statement was later
found to have included a number of
details falsely reported in the papers
at the time
as well as these apparent
inconsistencies in her story
psychologists called by the defense
weren't convinced by the repressed
memory theory in fact they argued the
theory itself
was little more than pseudoscience one
of them
elizabeth loftus explained to the courts
that memories
fade losing both detail and accuracy
over time
these weakened memories are incredibly
vulnerable to corruption by
post-event information facts
ideas inferences and opinions that only
become available to a witness
after the event has taken place once
this post-event information has wormed
its way insidiously into our memories
we believe it just as completely as we
do
are accurate recollections the argument
fell
on deaf ears a man's own daughter
accusing him of crimes as heinous as
rape and murder
is compelling stuff and despite the
prosecution not producing a shred
of actual physical evidence the jury
found george franklin guilty of murder
and he was sentenced to life
imprisonment franklin
would spend the next six years behind
bars
during which time he probably cursed
sigmund freud in every language he knew
before a district judge finally
overturns the guilty verdict
citing the case's reliance on eileen's
controversial repressed memories
and on a number of issues with how the
trial had been carried out
incredibly as franklin was set for
retrial
eileen claimed to have recovered
memories of her father committing two
additional rape murders during her
childhood
but before these new accusations even
made it to court
dna evidence proved conclusively
they couldn't be true as a result george
franklin's second trial was dropped
altogether and he was released george's
case
represented the first time in history
someone had been convicted
on the basis of an apparently repressed
memory
and it started an argument among
psychologists
therapists and psychiatrists as to
whether
repressed memories really exist or if
they are in fact
false memories masquerading as real ones
because despite being a pretty commonly
held belief
even today hard evidence for repressed
memories
is actually pretty thin on the ground
and it's an extremely tricky subject to
study
after all you can't exactly go around
inflicting extreme trauma on people
then waiting a few years and asking them
if they remember that time you forced
them to watch the spice girls movie
100 times back to back the debate around
repressed memories is still going on
today
but what experts can all agree on is the
fact that our memories are extremely
fallible
and understanding more about exactly how
fallible they
are is vitally important particularly
when eyewitness testimony plays such a
huge part in the criminal justice system
but where does that leave us it's a
little disconcerting to realize
we probably can't trust our memories
quite as much as we thought we could
after all how do we know who we really
are
if we can't be sure the experiences we
think we've lived
actually happened in reality there's no
reason for false memories to trigger
quite that level of existential crisis
whilst it's true many of the things you
remember didn't happen
quite how you think they did the vast
majority of the time the differences
between
your memory and reality are entirely
inconsequential still if you do ever
wake up one morning
convinced your dog started the great
fire of london
it's probably worth asking yourself
whether that one
might be a false memory before taking
your story to the newspapers
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you